ready for the weekend Bryce are you
ready for the weekend Andy I think so
so I'm excited this is a culmination of
a long time fans have been waiting three
years for this I know what are we
delivering are we getting Roni news are
we getting reboot news new cities what
can you tease me with
no new cities
maybe some news in the Roney Universe
okay okay
I'll take it you know a big Rumor for
this weekend is that you were going to
announce your retiring I just heard that
uh down the red carpet line
um that is news to me
and it's not happening yeah no I does
everyone want me to is that I don't
think so today you know the other
hacking into something that I didn't
expect the other half of that rumor is
that Craig Conover of all people would
take over for you on Watch What Happens
Live what
dude Craig who I love but doesn't even
watch his own show but like it's not
known as one of our greatest
broadcasters at this point I mean
okay that's interesting where did that
okay so now we know where that rumor
came from Craig you're starting rumors
about yourself
that is odd that is an interesting one
and you're doing a whole week of shows
in one weekend for watching diamonds
live what are you most looking forward
to about those well they're going to be
really great are you coming to any Bryce
I'm coming tonight okay great so the
Legends ball is going to be really
exciting we've got 140 Bravo Liberties
on one stage and then through the rest
of next week we've got um Queens of
shade uh we've got Dynamic Duos we have
Andrea Andy's mystery doorbell show
where anyone could pop through the door
and everybody will uh so the idea is
trying to Showcase as many Bravo
Liberties as we can uh and put
um surprising pairings together and uh I
have a lot of fun along the way I think
it's going to be great and we're coming
behind the scenes of the doorbell show
oh great great great okay good that's
gonna be so fun can we do a little state
of the reunion yes Beverly Hills okay
we've seen part one yep two more parts
to come of what still to come what
shocked you the most that you can tease
me with
I think the whole Kathy segment was
really shocking to me what you did to my
sister and you drove Lisa Vanderpump off
the show I mean the list can go on and
on listen
I can handle fighting
I can handle Petty arguments when it
comes down to kind of family and things
getting between family that's when it
gets kind of that's what it gets me and
so this was it was
um challenging for that reason
Kathy looks like she handled herself and
then some Kathy came prepared I didn't
know because last year at the reunion
she was kind of she dropped in and I
didn't have a sense that she was
necessarily familiar with the uvra this
year she knew what had to be done and
she did it and then we have Rinna your
social media is disastrous put me on was
what does the future look like for Rena
well uh you know what we kind of have
those discussions that now through the
end of after when the reunions air so uh
you know everybody's I think the key to
the success of this thing that it's been
going 16 years is that we take people
out we put people in and we try to keep
it fresh in terms of specifics of Rena
and anyone else I mean I think
everything's on the table but nothing to
announce about that right now Kathy's
not on the plane with us today because
she had a
breakdown at the nightclub that we were
all at that we saw I've known Kathy for
a long time more than some of the other
girls in the group like how bad could
the behavior been the fans think there
must be footage of this meltdown there
must be audio of this moment can you set
that straight if there was footage of
the Meltdown do you not think that we
would be air what would be the reason
that we would not air this honestly like
I would have loved if there was footage
of the Meltdown trust me we would be you
would have seen it so many times how
many times did we show the limo fight
between Kyle and Kim how many times I
mean we're not afraid to lean into drama
it's kind of what we do right yes
there's there's no protecting these
women if they do something I mean I
think that they I think that that's one
of the things that they realize that
everything's on the table if it happens
it's going to be shown
[Music]
thank you